- This video is brought to you by Keeps.
(upbeat music)
What's up, guys?
Michael here, and today, I'm gonna talk
about the thing that a lot of people
on the Internet are
talking about: Bo Burnham!
Anyone who was scrolling the Internet saw
that Bo dropped a bunch of outtakes
to his 2021 special, "Inside,"
and I've been excited to
talk about it ever since.
Now, Burnham's 2021
Netflix special, "Inside,"
was a full-on cultural sensation
and maybe one of the few
pieces of good pandemic art.
We talked about it last year.
Check out that video.
So, like the rest of the Internet,
I was super stoked to see
that he was putting out
a bunch of outtakes from the special,
and the new footage doesn't disappoint.
But it also raises a lot
of new questions, like,
can Burnham's self-imposed
creative isolation
teach us anything about ourselves?
Does reflecting on the
disappointing present
show us anything about the future?
And once and for all,
are comedians really the new philosophers?
Let's find out in this edition
of "A Philosopher Reacts
to Bo Burnham's 'The Inside Outtakes.'"
And of course, spoilers ahead for a thing
you've probably already watched
a bunch of times on YouTube.
But before we get into it,
I wanna tell you about
this week's sponsor, Keeps.
Keeps makes it easier and more affordable
for guys to prevent hair loss,
and since two out of three men
will experience male-pattern baldness
in some form by the time they're 35,
Keeps is relevant to a lot of people.
But with their subscription service,
you can fight back against hair loss
and hang on to the hair you have.
The process begins with
a free consultation
with a licensed Keeps
doctor, who can help decide
which combination of
over-the-counter medications
and FDA-approved prescriptions
are right for you.
These hair loss prevention
meds will arrive
at your home every three months,
so you won't have to set
up an annoying reminder
to pick up your refills.
As your treatment plan continues,
you can message your Keeps doctor 24/7
to update them on your progress
and to ask any questions you may have.
But here's one question
we can answer right now.
While individual results may vary,
it typically takes between
four and six months
to start seeing results.
If you're ready to take
action to prevent hair loss,
go to keeps.com/wisecrack
or click the link
in the description to receive
50% off your first order.
That's K-E-E-P-S.com/wisecrack.
Now, back to the show.
Now, Burnham's 2021 special, "Inside,"
explored the ways in
which digital capitalism
and the alienation it causes
is making life super un-chill.
- Maybe that, as a,
as a way of life forever,
maybe that's, um, not good.
- [Michael] It also featured
a now-legendary sock puppet
♪ Don'tcha know the world
is built with blood ♪
and featured maybe the catchiest song
to ever be written about a billionaire.
♪ Zuckerberg and Gates and Buffet ♪
♪ Amateurs can (beep) suck it ♪
♪ (beep) their wives, drink their blood ♪
♪ Come on, Jeff, get 'em ♪
But "The Inside Outtakes" is
actually a bit more inside
than "Inside" was, and
what I mean by that is,
the outtakes and the alts
and the weird fragments
and the grainy videos
of spiders are giving us
a lot more of an isolated
and personal take
on what Burnham was
seemingly going through
during the creation of "Inside,"
and I'm using the word
seemingly intentionally
because it's always hard
to tell where the boundary
between existence and
performance is for this guy.
Whereas "Inside's"
songs focused a lot more
on the digital trends and cultural forces
making things feel
really bad in the world,
on "The Inside Outtakes,"
a lot of these new songs focus more
on feeling bad and sad and depressed
at the individual level.
And if I can make a
really absurd comparison
between Burnham's guesthouse
and Plato's famous Cave,
it seems like in the outtakes,
Burnham is highlighting the fact
that understanding how the world works
doesn't necessarily make you any happier,
and in fact, really understanding
what's going on around you
might do the opposite and
make you pretty bummed.
Now, I got the chance to watch
it a couple of times now,
and I think if there is a kind
of implicit thesis statement
or thematic to the outtakes, we see it
in one of the first new songs,
which is called "The Future."
♪ Wake up every morning
at a quarter to 10 ♪
♪ Like, am I dying, is this real ♪
♪ All right, it's this again ♪
He's not feeling very good.
♪ I'm awoken by my daughter
as she jumps in my bed ♪
♪ I'm only kidding, I don't
have a kid, I crochet instead ♪
He's lying about a kid that he
doesn't have, which is good.
I mean, he's depressed.
During the song, Bo is
singing about the future,
and he seems depressed,
and maybe he's depressed
because of the future or
more darkly the lack thereof.
♪ Am I depressed, stressed ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ It's anyone's guess ♪
♪ I'll bother getting better
when I bother getting dressed ♪
Philosophers have long
talked about the experience
of being, to put it in highbrow
terms, super bummed out,
and whether it's because
they're being executed
by the state, like Socrates, or struggling
to find a rational basis
for their own existence,
like Descartes, or barely coping
with the cultural collapse
of meaning and truth,
like our old pals
Kierkegaard and Nietzsche,
philosophers have historically
had lots of reasons to be bummed.
And there's a contemporary
Italian philosopher
and theorist named Franco "Bifo" Berardi
who's written about
this and how in our era
the seeming lack of, like, a good future
that we're heading towards has led
to a pretty big wave of
depression and exhaustion.
For Berardi, depression can be
defined as "a lack of sense,
as an inability to find
sense through action,
through communication, through life.
The inability to find
sense is, first of all,
the inability to create it."
And finding sense in this context
is what philosophy aims to do, right?
Philosophy wants to
make sense of situations
that are complicated and
confusing and contradictory.
But what Berardi's saying is
that when we can't make sense
or find sense in a particular situation,
like maybe the world of
digital media and capitalism,
we struggle to create
and communicate sense.
And here, and throughout these outtakes,
Burnham seems to be saying
that contemporary life
doesn't make a lot of sense
and it's hard to make art and comedy
about a situation that doesn't make sense
and that this is all depressing.
Now, Berardi goes on to argue
that "depression allows us
to see what we normally
hide from ourselves
through the continuous circulation
of a reassuring collective narrative.
Depression sees what
public discourse hides.
Depression is the best
condition to access the void.
That is the ultimate truth.
At the same time, though,
depression paralyzes any ability
to act, to communicate, to share."
This also feels like a good way to explore
and explain what Burnham's doing here
because a type of depression
and grimness gets one closer
to the truth of how a situation really is,
but then you can't communicate
the truth of that thing,
which is kind of a pickle to be in
and a vibe I definitely got in "Inside"
and I think we're seeing
throughout this special as well.
Now, Bo is depressed, right?
And presumably, if you're
depressed, you feel bad,
and then you would wanna feel good,
and right here on this
social media platform,
for every one video of
charming cultural analysis,
there's, like, 100 videos
that will tell you how
to feel better or be more productive, um,
cure your anxiety, your ADHD or whatever,
and it seems like that's the sort of stuff
that Bo is looking for in this next song,
which is about how, damn it,
he just wants to feel good.
♪ Can you teach how to feel good ♪
The music's pretty,
but what he's saying,
♪ I just wanna feel good ♪
what he's saying is sad.
♪ I just wanna ♪
♪ I just wanna feel good ♪
You know, kinda desperate to feel good.
Now, building off the depressive
vibes we've already seen,
he's begging for some help to feel good,
which gets us to a bit of
a contradiction, right?
Does Burnham want to
have truth or happiness?
Because as we saw in those Berardi quotes,
truth can sometimes accompany feelings
of depression and despair.
Like, seeing how things
really are isn't always good
'cause sometimes how
things really are is bad.
And while there's been
philosophers, like Aristotle,
who associate truth and
purpose with happiness,
he doesn't mean, like, feeling good.
It means more acting
and living in accordance
with one's nature or purpose.
And I think this tension
is all over these outtakes
and the original special.
Does Bo want to find meaning
in everything that's happening
at the risk of that
meaning being depressing
or does he wanna feel good,
and by extension, do we want him
to potentially make us feel
bad on the way to meaning
or do we want the funny
song man to make us laugh?
Now, of course, over the past year,
we've seen more and more
answers to his question,
how do I feel good, all
over the Internet, right?
Whether it's online therapy,
online psychiatric pharmacies,
self-help podcasts, meme
accounts, online courses,
happiness is an industry, and of course,
and I think Burnham gets this,
there's an industry for
happiness on the Internet,
the Internet is the thing
that makes us unhappy...
Oh, boy.
Understanding why things are so bad
doesn't make you feel better
any more than understanding
why you're sick, right?
It doesn't magically make you feel better.
So maybe the best medicine
is laughter. Probably not.
- I used to perform comedy on a stage,
um, in front of, uh,
people, living humans,
and I would try to be funny.
- Trying to be funny is rough, you know?
You wanna be, like, naturally
funny. Trying's hard.
- And then the audience
would sometimes laugh,
and that was really helpful,
because I would hear their laughter,
and that would let me know
that what I was doing was funny to them.
- All right, he's doing
something interesting here.
He's basically getting at
another aspect of loneliness
and isolation, which is that in his case,
it's hard to make comedy alone
'cause he's dependent on laughter.
This is important because in this sense,
comedy reflects the intersubjective nature
of human existence, right?
We're dependent on other people
to arrive at ideas, to create meaning,
even to have, like, a full
conception of ourselves,
and it seems like what
he's getting at as well
is that in a state of quarantine
or just state of our modern digital life,
there's a lot of
atomization and alienation
in all these digital spaces, right?
And the Internet has
this effect of making us
both atomized and isolated individuals
and part of one huge, homogenous dataset
all at the same time
so that rather than being
fully formed individuals
existing in some dialectical
relationship with each other,
we're just isolated units screaming
into a digital void all at the same time.
Sounds fun.
So what do we do if
we're lonely, isolated,
looking for friends that understand us?
We listen to podcasts, of course.
- PC culture. Man, it's, uh...
- It's (beep) exhausting, bro.
- Right, bro. It's (beep) out of control.
- It's exhausting.
- It's just...
Our culture has been taken over
by a group of SJW feminist freaks-
- Feminists, yeah.
- who, uh, who...
- That must be hard, to be a comedian.
I feel really bad for him.
- We as comedians are philosophers.
All right?
- Yes, dude.
- Lenny Bruce, Richard Pryor.
- We hold the mirror, or, uh-
- History-changing cultural figures,
and you need to recognize that, all right?
- Okay, so Burnham's podcast bro
or podcast bros persona,
it says something that
gets thrown around a lot,
which is "We as comedians
are philosophers,"
and as someone whose two
favorite cultural pursuits
are philosophy and comedy,
I've long been both fascinated by
and skeptical of this claim.
It's something that usually
gets said by comedians
who are defending themselves
after being criticized
for saying deemed
problematic or offensive.
And the pattern, you know,
usually goes something like,
comedian says something racist
or sexist or transphobic
and audiences get mad at them
and then the comedians and their fans say,
as a philosopher, it's their, you know,
job to push the limits and
hold a mirror to society.
Now, it is true that lots of philosophers
have been persecuted, critiqued, canceled
by governments, by the
church, by the media.
Socrates got the death penalty.
Spinoza got exiled.
Kierkegaard was ridiculed in the press.
Marx got kicked out of
his home country, right?
So this makes the two Bos
just like those guys, right?
No, of course not.
Because for the most part,
when philosophers have made people upset,
it's by speaking truth to power
or what comedians might call
punching up and not punching down.
So when Socrates questioned
Athens' rich and powerful
or Spinoza asked questions
about the nature of God
or Marx criticized how industrial
labor affects humanity,
they weren't taking shots
at already-marginalized groups, right?
They were poking at the
ideologies used by those in power,
so the state, the church, the factory.
Now, another thing you've might've noticed
is right when they started
talking about this,
like, comedians-as-philosopher idea,
an ad came on the screen
for Manstuff Dick Spray,
and I think it's both very
funny as a name for a product
but also intentional, right?
Just as they're talking
about being history-changing
cultural figures,
we see that they're also
selling dick spray to make money
while they're doing their philosophy,
and this does make me think
of the Greek sophists,
who Plato and Socrates hated,
because they offered their
philosophical services
at a price, and for people
like Plato and Socrates,
the idea that wisdom could be
purchased was very, very sus.
Okay, the podcast guys were intense.
Let's see a more sensitive and
introspective version of Bo
in this next clip.
- Since I started so young,
basically every (beep) joke,
every sort of misstep is, is, um...
There's a lot of material
that I'm just really embarrassed by
and makes me cringe for a lot of reasons,
and, uh, just edgy, stupid...
- Okay, so as you see,
Bo's being very earnest here,
talking about how hard it's been
to have so much of his
life documented online.
- I often wish that I could just,
you know, start over and
without all the... (sighs)
- What's most interesting to
me is what pops up onscreen,
and it's a thumbnail to
click a link to watch a video
called "OMG! DID I JUST (beep)
A MINECRAFT PINEAPPLE???"
with a classic YouTube thumbnail face
of Bo screaming like that,
and I think both this
and the dick spray ad in the podcast thing
is bringing up this question, right?
Can a earnest desire
for meaning or self-exploration coexist
with trying to sell (beep) or just get you
to give more of your
attention away, right?
Can truth and commerce
coexist in a genuine way?
And I think in doing this,
Burnham's both pointing at himself
as well as a lot of other
people who make content,
maybe on this website,
on YouTube, right here.
Okay, enough about that.
Let's see what he has
to say about the future.
- The future is in front of now,
do you know what I mean?
- The future is in front of now.
Yeah, it makes sense.
It kinda doesn't sound
like it makes sense,
but then it makes sense.
And we got another ad.
I just gotta point it out.
"Mental Health Awareness
Decade at Kohl's."
I just realized what this
meant on the last take,
because to be honest like Bo Burnham,
this is the second take of this section.
I'm just being honest with you
in the way he does in the special.
And on that take, I
realized that there's a joke
where it says "All
laceless shoes 60% off."
It's not even a joke.
It's just really dark, but there you go.
Now, we've talked about
the future already in this,
and here, Burnham's exploring the idea
that it feels bad
sometimes when we realize
that the future is gonna be made up
of all the stuff happening now, right?
The logical extension of
what's already happening.
It's like if you're a kid
and you get home from
school and you're hungry
and you see the ingredients for dinner
on the table and you hate them.
They're the ingredients for
your least favorite meal.
You know that no matter what,
your dinner's gonna be made
of those ingredients you don't like.
But this is something that
our bud Berardi talks about
in his book "After the
Future," where he says,
"The rise of the myth
of the future is rooted
in modern capitalism and the experience
of expansion of the economy and knowledge.
The idea that the future will be better
than the present is not a natural idea
but the imaginary effect
of the peculiarity
of the bourgeois production model."
Okay, so the idea here is that
there was a certain vision
of modernity, let's say
around the '50s, that said,
"Everything's going to get better.
Industry is gonna be more efficient.
Technology is gonna become more advanced.
It's gonna make all of our lives better."
But according to Berardi,
what we've seen is the slow
cancellation of the future.
It started in, like, the '60s and the '70s
into the '80s and kind
of intensified since,
and this idea of the slow
cancellation of the future
basically means that time has stopped.
We're not really experiencing
any meaningful cultural progress.
We don't sense that a
better future is present.
This uncanny feeling is accompanied
by what scholar Mark Fisher called
"a deflation of expectations," right?
So we kind of stop hoping or
imagining things getting better
because, like, what's the point?
Okay, this is where Bo, a few Bos,
give a sort of State of the
Union on content creation.
- My name is Bo Burnham,
I am a lifelong content creator,
and I am absolutely thrilled
to be speaking with you tonight.
- This one's way too real
'cause people really talk like this.
And as you see, more Bos
start coming onscreen. Yeah.
And this one's hard to suss
out because as you see,
there's eventually three Bos speaking,
so if there's lines that I
missed that are your favorites,
please drop them in the comments.
But he definitely shouts out the names
of some folks at the beginning,
Bezos, Dorsey, Zuckerberg,
who are actively involved
in trying to shape our collective future,
but the part of this that stands out to me
is when the third monologuing
Burnham talks about-
- This steady, formless feeling
that hangs over everything,
this untamable, aimless urgency,
this sense that all of this is
going to burst at any moment.
- the fear of what will
happen when it ends
and the deeper fear of
never hitting the wall
and this feeling never
ending, never slowing down,
an endless and pointless climb
towards a terrible and dense nothing.
Okay, and here, it seems like
he's talking about an anxiety
that's produced by both
a lack of a clear future
and the fact that the
future is in the hands of,
you know, the Bezoses and
Dorseys and Zuckerbergs
of the world, that they
get to determine things.
So it's either their future
or a potentially scarier
future made by someone else,
but in all these cases,
the modernist dream
of indefinite and endless
progress seems very dead.
Berardi has this to say about the future.
He says, "The future becomes a threat
when the collective
imagination becomes incapable
of seeing possible alternatives to trends,
leading to devastation,
increased poverty, and violence.
The paralysis of the will,
the impossibility of politics
is the historical context of
today's depression epidemic."
So again, he's saying when we
both can't imagine a future
and we feel like we can't
determine that future,
we feel pretty bad, and
I think it's interesting
that Bo is talking
about content right here
'cause there's another quote
from Berardi, you guessed it,
who says, "Despite all its rhetoric
of novelty and innovation,
neoliberal capitalism
has gradually but
systematically deprived artists
of the resources necessary
to produce the new."
And again, we see this tension.
We have Bo Burnham,
someone who seemingly wants
to create art, talking about what it means
to try to create art and
meaning in this context,
this accelerating, hypercapitalist,
futurist model of digital hell.
That's a bummer.
This one's just a bummer.
Okay, let's keep going.
- The thing that I'm
writing about isn't ending,
so it's hard to end whatever this is.
- Okay, all good things
and all sad things must come to an end,
so this is Burnham talking
about why he's ending
the filming right here.
I don't know, maybe it's just
that Netflix called and was like,
"Dude, we gave you all this money.
You need to give us a special
or we're gonna sue you."
This is super important
and I think ties it together
in a really nice way,
or ties it together in not
tying it together, right?
Because he wants something
to make sense of it all,
a big idea, a theme,
and I think to both sense of this special
but to also make sense of
everything happening in the world.
And remember that Berardi,
we read this quote before,
says that an inability to
find sense can be tied up
with depression and exhaustion, you know?
And Bo here is saying the more he waits
for an ending that'll tie it all together,
he just feels (beep),
so he just has to stop,
to just stop doing it.
Now, in the Berardi book
I've been quoting a lot,
he kinda gets to this point as well
and talks about, how do we stop?
What do we do?
If the future is canceled, like,
do we just hang out or something?
And he says this.
He says, "I answer the
question, why resist?
Why persist in seeking
autonomy from power?
Where is the hope?
The hope is in the limits of
my knowledge and understanding.
My knowledge and understanding
do not show the possibility
of any development of
the present catastrophe
in agreement with social well-being.
But the catastrophe is exactly the point
where a new landscape
is going to be revealed.
I must resist simply because I cannot know
what will happen after the future.
And I must preserve the consciousness
and sensibility of social solidary,
of human empathy, of gratuitous activity,
of freedom, equality, and fraternity.
Just in case, right?"
So the optimism here is basically,
even if in the consciousness we have now,
we can't see things getting better,
if all our logic and reason say
things are gonna keep getting pretty bad,
and there's some good stuff in
the "Inside" special itself,
like the "Funny Feeling" song,
that are kind of about that,
but Berardi's saying
after the catastrophe,
after the bad thing happens,
a new landscape's gonna be revealed,
so we have to hope for that.
And when he says, you know,
"Just in case, right?",
he kinda says we gotta keep
hoping, keep resisting,
keep trying, because what
else are we gonna do?
And I think there's a little bit
of a similarity with
what Burnham is doing.
Okay, one last thing I wanna look at.
I promise, just one last thing
and then we'll call this a day.
Okay, so I just wanna look
at the final image we have
in the whole outtakes special.
(waves crashing)
So it's not a pop-up
telling us to go to Netflix
and watch his special.
It's a few seconds of the
ocean hitting the shore,
which stands out in contrast
to the last hour or so
of a sad man in a dark room.
Now, I don't wanna read
too much into this,
but to read too much into this,
it seems like he's hinting
that in the isolated digital realm
in which he's existed
for most of this special,
in which I'm sure many of us exist,
that space isn't where we're
gonna find truth or meaning or,
like he said, the thing
that ties it all together.
So like the guy in Plato's
Allegory of the Cave,
for us to leave the cave to find truth,
Burnham needs to leave his guesthouse
and maybe we, if we are looking
for those things as well,
need to unplug a bit.
Go to the beach, wherever
your beach might be.
But what do you guys think?
Is the "Inside Outtakes" special
filling the Burnham-shaped
hole in your heart,
or did our guy just have a bunch of files
he wanted to take out of his hard drive
so he dropped them on YouTube?
Let us know what you
think in the comments,
and let us know as well
what you thought about it
if you have any ideas
on what's going on here.
And we'd love to hear as
well if there's other content
you'd love to see me talk about
from a philosophical perspective.
Such a huge thanks to all of our patrons.
It means a lot to us.
Please check out our Patreon
page if you haven't recently,
we have some fun new stuff
on there, and also be sure
to check out our new
stream, "Wisecrack Live."
It takes place every Thursday,
11:00 a.m. Pacific, right here.
You should go.
You're gonna love it.
Smack that subscribe button
like you're aggressively
putting peanut butter
on your sad sandwich, and
don't forget to ring that bell.
As always, thank you so
much for watching. Later.
(upbeat music)